the body of kharsa bar is laid to rest
the 23 year old was one of six people
killed in what the u.s. called defensive
precision strikes on Khattab Hezbollah
in southern Iraq but Sabah's family says
he wasn't a fighter but a daily laborer
working at Karbala Airport who had
nothing to do with the iranian-backed
group he worked inside the airport
getting paid $8 per day now that he's
dead
who's gonna think about his kids his
wife his mother where's their guilt
sabado leaves behind a pregnant wife two
children and a family consumed with
grief like many other Iraqis the family
is angry at the US and the Iranian
backed groups for settling scores on
Iraqi soil
Hazara this conflict is between Iran and
America it's none of our business they
should go out and fight it out between
themselves the u.s. strikes followed a
barrage of rockets fired at the Taji
military base north of Baghdad on March
11th killing two American and one
British soldier the Pentagon described
the US response as a success we assess
that each location stored weapons that
would enable lethal operations against
us and coalition forces in Iraq we also
assessed that the destruction of these
sites will degrade Khatib Hizballah's
ability to conduct future strikes but
the American reprisal was followed by a
second rocket attack on target just a
day later raising doubts about the
effectiveness of the US military action
a total of nine people were killed and
dozens wounded in the latest three
tit-for-tat attacks many of the
casualties were members of the Iraqi
security forces who worked with both
sides we don't accept being in the
middle while the two sides to rate their
weapons against each other this has
caused a lot of damage for the Iraqi
army the Iraqi joint operations command
announced both the US and what it
cautiously calls the other side for not
respecting its authority as the highest
military body and for not giving it a
chance to manage the crisis rock for say
there was no chance to finish the
investigation into the first rock
the American side directly reacted with
its strike on Iraqi facilities that
included the army bases and employees
and also the other side started their
attacks which only complicated the
situation but the Iraqi government has
never attributed blame nor has it
published results of investigations for
any of the two dozen rocket attacks that
targeted the coalition over the past six
months the Iraqi government appears
unwilling or unable to stop the groups
responsible for attacks on bases that
house coalition personnel instead it is
called for the implementation of
January's parliamentary decision to
expel all foreign troops from Iraq the
coalition has begun withdrawing soldiers
from smaller bases to consolidate them
in fewer locations and although US
officials say that this move is not
related to the latest rocket attacks it
could pave the way for a partial troop
drawdown over the next few months Simona
14:00 al Jazeera Baghdad